[Musique]
c'était la stupéfaction dimanche soir au
dolby theater d'hollywood lors de la 94
ème cérémonie des oscars l'acteur will
smith a littéralement perdu son sang
froid face à une mauvaise blague de
chris rock sur sa femme
si vous disparaissez plus tôt on va
rester au moment de recevoir son oscar
quelques minutes plus tard j'espère que
nouveau il a tenu à présenter ses
excuses à chris rock sur son compte
instagram comportement la nuit dernière
aux oscars était inacceptable et
inexcusable
je voudrais publiquement te demander
pardon en crise ce que j'ai fait était
déplacée et j'ai eu tort entre les deux
hommes la hache de guerre semble déjà
enterré mais l'académie a tout de même
ouvert une enquête si will smith devrait
bel et bien conserver son oscar il
pourrait s'exposer à des sanctions
disciplinaires
[Musique]
on adore la musique
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ce
quartier où il suit on n'a pas parlé
hier à gilles verdez vous auriez fait
pareil si c'était sur fatton
oui parce que on attaque directement sa
femme qui répliquent d'homme à homme moi
je suis pour et je suis désolé qu'il se
soit excusé et un rayon social et moi ce
qui m'énerve syrie je vais vous dire
c'est qu'on leur fait payer à ce couple
là tout ce qu'ils sont on leur fait
payer le fait d'être un couple libre
elle elle n'est pas aimé là bas il faut
savoir qu'elle est extrêmement france
elle a par exemple avoué que quand elle
a rencontré le rappeur tupac elle
l'était dealeuse de drogue l avouer ça
oui et donc on leur fait payer aux gens
c'est dingue comme isabelle on leur fait
payer tout ça aujourd'hui c'est malsain
moi je les soutiens a fait nommer temps
maintenant que vous connaissez tous pack
un pack de bières
mais je suis désolé il mélange
absolument tout moi je m'en fous de son
passé et à elle et à lui ce que je vois
c'est un mec qui colle littéralement un
pain dans la gueule moi je suis bien
pourquoi du réseau l'oscar parce qu'il
l'a gagnée en tant qu'acteur donc là
faut pas tout mélanger la raison
d'enjeux qui se soit excusé ça me semble
la moindre des choses et qu'elle des
sanctions disciplinaires ça me semble
aussi la moindre des choses oui oui qui
veut parler on est beaucoup trop sympa
avec tout le cynisme parce que c'est
will smith vous rendez pas compte de la
violence
si c'est qui surprise tarifs démission
c'est le vestiaire de l'équipe de france
de foot au qui va jouer dans un instant
non ça va l'être héros sans nu je t'aime
mon frérot au
soyez bon ce soir saluons frère soit bon
toi tu es toujours bon ben je t'embrasse
à lui offert au
nom
[Rires]
et les appels aux vestiaires oui bah oui
oued à 21h30 pour dîner
non mais
on se rend match et
on se rend pas compte de la violence du
geste imaginez ça arrive sur un nouveau
plateau à un intervenant qui giflent
quelqu'un vous convient de leur vie en
détention non mais non rien c'est d'une
violence inouïe et pourquoi en fait on
dit rien parce que ça fait tellement
fake 11e' bon bah ça va mais c'est
extrêmement grave de gifler quelqu'un en
direct pour moi c'est inacceptable il
doit bien de son ouïe ouïe
mathieu l'ordre c'est lors de la loi
c'est la loi
honneur et leur durée et leur dire
quelque chose j'accepte et je pense
qu'il faut accepter totalement les
excuses commerce intérieur bien sûr will
smith a pas rêvé le petn est un peu
c'est le couple elle est très très mal
et on voit bien que voter une telle
violence c'est que c'était
malheureusement le couple elle est pas
très bien sûr la goutte d'eau un couple
qui va bien ça s'énerve pas comme ça
donc mais suivant par là c'est que
j'accepte totalement ses excuses très
bien acceptée en revanche en revanche
oui bien sûr il faut lui retirer son
oscar ça va parce que c'est
bien que devant des milliards de dollars
adaptateur mais devant des camions et
c'est le pe est il à mathieu c'est
quelqu'un mathieu mathieu salariés de
voir ce qu'a reconnu ce qu'a reconnu le
talon non non non non non non non
academy l'académie des oscars des césars
échec patent c'est le talent dans mes
habitués aux pensées j'avais bien sûr
excuses acceptées il pourra revenir en
gagner un prochain mais celui là pour
lui retirer mais sinon c'est trop
saint-louis quoi il s'est excusé il a
donné un mur beaucoup de points des
violences sans du régime devant des
milliards de personnes nées des gamins
mais à trice alors je suis comme gilles
j'ai enquêté j'ai appelé mon agent aux
états unis non c'est vrai le
rattachement de tobin et
les infos donc en fait cette polémique
ça a complètement divisé on parle que de
ça parle plus du tout des oscars des
autres prix jours et même au sein de
l'académie les gens se sont engueulés
parce que sur le moment personne n'a
réagi et la chaîne et l'académie
personne n'a réellement ils sont chauds
que c'est pas un fake c'est parce qu'ils
l'ont dit ils étaient pris de court il
savait pas quoi faire ils avaient peur
que parce que ça à cliver aussi les
célébrités il ya ceux qui défendent will
smith et à ceux qui défendent croissance
et donc il était très très embêté et
maintenant tout le monde se rejette la
faute donc ils vont être obligés de
prendre des sanctions pas lui enlever
son oscar mais ce qui va se passer s'il
va peut-être être suspendue l'académie
pendant un certain temps et puis là il
se prépare à faire un film qui va être
extraordinaire apparemment avec un rôle
oscarisable et malheureusement il pourra
peut-être alors on verra ce qu'ils
décident de faire mais pourra peut-être
ne pas être un prétendant à l'oscar vous
comprenez sa réaction voyez fait pareil
fait une mauvaise blague son mari est
malade et voilà et on nous dit voilà
j'ai pas elle a les cheveux rasés parce
qu'elle a un cancer par confesser de la
glace moi je me lève et je lui casse la
tête absolument
et
alors le passé ça m'est déjà arrivé
d'aller chercher quelqu'un qui avait ma
part et de ma femme sert à rien oui bah
oui ça guillon ah oui thierry serrés qui
me rappelle sur le plateau jean battault
de chassieu j'ai senti sa femme à nos
services étaient chier dessus elle est
nommée au sens propre il espère revenir
dessus vraiment la rue pine qu'elles
partent comment il a fait mais il avait
très peur vraiment live et après vous
l'avez dit quoi raconter une robe en
europe puisque il m'avait il y avait
vraiment chier semble sur ma famille et
c'est en fait il est venu ici je suis
loin de ma forme et si l'on me suis
beaucoup dessus il devrait donc tu
aimerais qu il avait dit ils habitent on
connaît midi quand on voit ses grands
parents quand on voit ce qu'est de musc
et son père quand on voit ce qu'il est
devenu on est très inquiet pour la santé
du petit dernier enzo ouais ça m'avait
rendu fou en fait et alors qu'ils staff
et moi j'étais là bas je venais plus
péter la gueule je n'ai pas fait parce
que voilà citadis italie morila il a
rien dit c'est celle subie au pardon
j'ai visité pas méchant tout ça mais
vous parce qu'il a à b parce qu'il n'a
pas de couilles mais mais voilà nommé le
passage à l'accès pour les sauvages et
oui mais tous les vrais cnrd on est à
lui il est bien fait les bienfaits ou un
bel exemple tu es content
sur quelqu'un qui est malade parce
qu'effectivement elle a les cheveux
rasés parce qu'elle est une maladie moi
je fais une blague devant le monde
entier et bah je me lève et je finisse
de
cadre aux îles et humoriste il a fait de
la scène où chantent ils habitent toutes
les armes pour répondre avec beaucoup
d'humour pour répondre devant l'académie
autre chose à moi j'ai là là on a vu une
racaille qui arrivait qu'une violence
raide amoureux
voilà encore une fois tu dis une bêtise
parce qu'on se donne pas tu cautionnes
de la violence comme un charme moi je
n'ai jamais vu autant de violence que ce
soit en france aux états unis maintenant
la violence est partout et vous lecteurs
[Applaudissements]
et pendant huit ans dans leur show des
oscars will smith n'avait pas trop l'air
trop affectée regardez-la réussi à
passer un bon moment malgré tout ce
qu'il a dans ces regards des saillies
ses excuses après
[Musique]
vous savez bien qu'on aurait fait pareil
que will smith il
savait bien qu aux etats unis ce sont
les spécialistes des excuses après avoir
fait des merdes c'est pareil pinto est
ce que tu aurais fait pareil la question
les bien sûr pas l'image qu'il a eu
raison ah ouais quand même si je n'aime
pas la violence oui parce que ont
sûrement pas de sa femme faut pas se
laisser passer ça en revanche les
retirer de ce cas hors de question et je
peux vous dire que whoopi goldberg qui
fait passer à l'action donc oui wahlberg
il appelle lui
à sisteron exceptionnel exact mais il
fait partie de l'académie des oscars ne
veux pas l'exclure sa prime ne sera pas
exclue les critères d'acceptabilité
alors alors là j ça parce qu'il voulait
ce que ce serait d'enlever vous n'êtes
pas d'accord mais je trouve que ça banal
en fait c'est alors sur de cette gifle
les excuses heureusement qui les a fait
elles sont très bien sont claires nettes
et précises moi je laisserais son nascar
malgré tout bah oui mais voilà mais
c'est juste le degré zéro je trouve deux
voilà de l'ess de la civilisation c'est
la violence n'a été vous c'est un disque
d'inzaghi géraldine et mathieu
absolument indigne heureusement que
chris rock à un esprit beaucoup plus
magnanime que vous il n'a pas porté
plainte à des émissions de télé pendant
des heures puisse-t-il ainsi il ya des
émissions de télé pendant des heures
qu'il incite à porter plainte comme ils
portent pas plainte et qui a pas eu
d'armé temps mais will smith ni de
blessures la police n'ouvre pas une au
but et ben c'est sous la halle où les
gens lui disent porter plainte ou des
dosettes en mai mais je comprends tout à
fait j'aurais fait exactement pareil si
j'avais la force de wigan a eu très mal
un chris rock voilà moi je l'aurais fait
là il l'a fait il l'a fait avec chris
rock voisine
je lui dis bravo je trouve que c'est
génial ce qu'il a fait on défend sa
femme oui les abeilles maurice il sait
se défendre verbalement ils promettent
spirituelle sur scène sans pour un coût
points bêtement à l'autre ce que tintin
florisens partant une gifle
qu'il est une espèce d'immunité parce
que c'est où ils souffrent vous avez
kanye west qui a un chemin qui harcèle
sa femme c'est pas bien non plus en
ligne il se fait boycotter des grammy
awards
j'ai une beigne en direct un mec il se
fait tout le monde dit que c'est génial
arrêté il aurait pu le faire déjà hors
antenne pourquoi le faire à l'antenne
déjà ça je trouve s'interroge est ce que
ça veut dire cyril série ça veut dire
que demain je n'importe quoi vraiment
elle a ensuite eu quelqu'un de ma
famille je le prends mal je me lève oui
je mets une énorme gifle demain je fais
et je m'excuse passerait la main je suis
assez vieux fresne très belle séquence
est ce que sans déconner le lendemain je
suis sure they play roule non mais il a
raison qu'ils seraient sanctionnés il
serait sans doute nos actionnaires et
bien sûr tabac seraient mises à pied
sans sa maison tout ça on voit la joie
quand il a l'exemple est bon il se passe
ça
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
jamais giflé
gillard à l'iss après oui il ya quand
même un enjeu aussi à la question de lui
enlever son oscar parce que si on leur
enlève son oscar ça veut dire qu'on
donne les oscars avec sursis ça veut
dire que si jamais on mais l'avocate là
on est vrai si jamais on découvre dans
les sms qu'on comprenait son geste ou
pas alors je cours à lessard accepte pas
on ne peut pas accepter la violence va
n'importe quelle manière qu'elles soient
à mais si jamais on lui enlève son oscar
on déprécie l'oscar aussi ont déprécié
la valeurs et l'oscar s'avère qu'on
donne aux oscars et qu'on peut l'enlever
à n'importe quel moment si on découvre
quelque chose de choquant sur quelqu'un
dans le passé le présent et le futur
ouais c'est vrai car la raison alors
aidons cl oui et heureusement que tous
les deux sont de la même couleur de peau
parce que si oui si on avait été blanc
et m'a alors j'aurais entendu gilles
verdière dit mon dieu ça va de la cl
d'eau près quand j'ai demandé le double
sommet ne même pas osé de dire belle et
troublante sur le noir donc ça aurait
été juste récupéré par tous d'une
manière obscène donc c'est pour ça que
dans tous les cas et c'est soit blanc
qu'on soit noir il ne faut pas être
violent est insupportable parce que
voilà c'est à quelle chance connu le
soin de blacks ça répète une émeute
il avait déjà giflé un homme
publiquement sénat moscou en 2012
pendant la promotion de men in black 3
vous avez vu ce au paa s'était fait
piéger par un faux journaliste et ils
avaient mal réagi regard des accords
liste
aucunement
[Applaudissements]
et
moi et moi j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer will smith ah oui c'est un
amour de ma voilà vraiment quelle bravo
série sanaa mohammed ameen après après
il a fait une erreur en scop il y avait
il y avait d'autres choses il était
série c'est la deuxième fois la
maîtrise des dossiers le journaliste
essayé de l'embrasser sur la cession à
lui rouler une pelle et n'a pas voulu et
l'autre a insisté donc il l'a repoussée
céline claque il est violent ce n'est
pas vrai c'est parce que tu connais pas
un ne te connais pas assez rythmés mais
il est violent ça se voit non bah ouais
non on reparle du contexte on pas de la
blague café chris rock sur sa femme qui
est malade et qui rit quelques crânes
rasés arrêtez vous dépasser tout et
pourtant ce mardi matin mais moi si
bernard montiel et puis quelqu'un sur ce
plateau fait une blague alors j'ai mon
fils qui est malade et qui me blesse à
me lever il fait une gamme dans la
gueule en direct absolument absolument
pourra t on fait là alors qu'on rigole
il est pas malade en six
questions à poser à mathieu géraldine la
chantre de la bonne conscience et moi
autres appareils oui mais toi bon la
vôtre
notre fameux démarre mal et que votre
femme ou votre main votre femme ou votre
et jeudi mais voilà si jamais votre
femme ou votre homme est insultée par
rapport à sa maladière quelqu'un public
gauthier traîné dans la boue vous vous
laisser faire comme ça allez ça passe
parce que c'est un comique parce qu'on
est en public ne réagissaient pas et
puis c'est ce qu'on
appelle les chéris il ya une analyse de
notre président francs capitaux qui me
dit alors je m'arrête je n'accepte pas
ce qu'il a fait mais il est juste très
connu voilà merci franchetto
grave c'est que gilles pour lui gilles
associe forcément la réponse à la
violence est ce que c'est que ce monde
gilles mais lui répond de dix mille
façons tu peux défendre tu peux leur
répondre et même une femme à thieu
mathieu combattants et mathieu ya plein
de gens qui dit il a vu rouge il a réagi
mais enfin écoutez on l a vu rouge s'est
séparé hier c'est pas un chauffeur
routier qui est habitué à tout ça c'est
un acteur et connaît les caméras il
connaît tout ça il me dit ça fait 30 ans
il a qu'il allait les people les matches
aller ça s'arrête et derrière lui c'est
quelqu'un qui connaît tout ça serait
pardonnée effectivement de quelqu'un qui
n'est pas habitué cela te rends compte
que pendant les oscars des milliards
regarder se lève y marche ça prend 10
secondes il va balancer l'énorme gifle
mon pauvre gilles et du niveau important
a été qu'est ce qu'il ya il a porté ses
fruits
vous auriez aimé vous les femmes que
votre homme face à non non j'aurais
préféré qu'il lui répondre quelque chose
dont
vous auriez adoré non ces chats dessine
depuis cinq mois passés d'affaires mais
c'est quoi ton mari est bien un type qui
me draguer dans un départ à tort à gué
dans un marais mon mari s'est précipité
sur lui et a menacé de faire le coup de
main on était fiancé et moi j'ai pas du
tout aimé pas du tout aimé je le fais
savoir devant le mexique 1 1 et en plus
c'est presque misogyne il s'est laissé
entendre qu aujourd'hui dirhams 6 en
effet besoin de protéger
oui c'est ça c'est ça ben non et lui il
est parti loin les noms mais je la
trouvais ça n'a elle pas mal
voilà ça c'est d'accord un peu vécu il
menaça bon ah oui oui oui oui oui donc
vous vous auriez frappé la personne en
moi jamais la violence
doit jamais vraiment que ses couilles je
connais c'est moi j'aurais dit écoute
c'est vraiment pas sympa
c'est pas porter ses couilles 1 c'est un
signe d'impuissance exactement ma motion
et si j'ai une gueule le faire et le
faire aux oscars sur la scène des oscars
des milliards de gens brillants
c'est de dire si vous ne feriez pas
exactement à quoi l'appareil bon sexe
merci